hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one key concept in stoic ethics that
Cato sets out for us as a representative
of stoicism in Cicero's on the ends book
three is this notion of appropriate acts
and the Latin for that is actually a
thick IAM officia in the plural the
Greek for that is cafe cone and this
played an incredibly important role
within stoic ethics in part because the
appropriate act or another way of
translating this is moral duties are
things that make sense for us to do
things that we ought to do but they're
not by themselves intrinsically good as
a matter of fact the Stoics reserve the
whole notion of what is intrinsically
good for virtue or moral goodness as
such and actions that that represent
virtue stemming from virtue and we'll
get to that in just a moment so what are
these these appropriate acts or if you
like it doesn't work quite so well here
to translate it as duties but you could
say actions in accordance with duty so
Cato tells us that some of these stem
from what he calls the primary impulses
or objects or another way of being a bit
more literal in translation principles
putting kippis of nature and one of the
things that the Stoics believed was that
every single being from its inception as
soon as it is self-aware
it loves itself and it attempts to make
its being continue and not just
existence but its physical frame you
could say it protects its physical
integrity and so some act stem from this
this primary impulse of preserving what
we translate as its own Constitution
status in Latin which would include our
physical
form so that would include actions like
take nourishment right making sure that
we're eating the right things to
actually get ourselves what it is that
we need for our bodies and you know if
we wanted to be very modern about this
we could say well you should consult
nutrition and see you know whether the
things that you're eating are actually
good for you or not and if you find out
that they're not good for you then it
would be an appropriate act to change
your diet exercising could be one of
those sorts of things moving from place
to place to avoid hazards to you know
make yourself feel better about your
physical frame all those sorts of things
could fall under this primary impulse of
preserving one's Constitution then in
the same paragraph he goes a little bit
further and it says that another set of
appropriate actions come from taking
what is in accordance with nature and
rejecting or pushing away from us its
opposites
so we have to think both what is in
accordance with our own human nature and
not just human nature in the sense of oh
well people are bad that's human nature
that's not the way the Stoics saw it so
we have to think about things like
familial affection you know that would
be something that is from nature and is
in accordance with nature and he talks
about that a little bit later in book
three how should we treat our children
how should we treat those with whom we
are in a household those are things that
are in accordance with nature and fit
into this notion of appropriate acts now
another way of understanding appropriate
acts and this gets to that issue of are
we dealing with virtues or not is that
appropriate acts really deal with what
the Stoics called indifference these are
not things that we are necessarily
indifferent to that's placing the
indifference on the side of the subject
rather they're things that we ought to
be indifferent to that that is we ought
to have a certain detachment from them
because they literally do not make a
difference in relation to happiness in
the full sense eudaimonia or Beata vita
for the latin translation of that or to
having you know moral goodness or virtue
because the Stoics think that these
three and three things happiness moral
virtue and moral goodness are all tied
together in one big thing there at the
top you could say and then at the bottom
would be the opposites of that moral
badness vices misery right but there's a
whole bunch of stuff in between like say
wealth or poverty physical health or
sickness the amount of time that we
enjoy something for or suffer something
for our social status all sorts of
things along those lines are our
appearance are we good-looking or ugly
those are all strictly speaking
indifference now the Stoics didn't think
that because of that they have no
ordering whatsoever but they just don't
come they don't conduce to or combine
themselves into the good or the bad and
you might say well wait a second here
didn't you just say that appropriate act
stemmed from say preserving one's own
Constitution obviously a living thing
values its own life and its own body
being in you know some sort of integral
shape yes the Stoics would say but that
is not the same thing as moral goodness
which lies in virtue so there's an
entire vast realm of things that are
that are in difference they don't make a
difference and we do still have to work
with them so these are the things that
are not placed among the goods and Bad's
and Cicero and Cato will tell us here in
this book that appropriate acts
themselves be
cuz they bear on indifference they are
not themselves placed among things that
are good in the in the full sense or bad
they can be useful they can be harmful
they can have all sorts of other
predicates supplied to them they can be
preferred indifference or rejected and
difference although appropriate acts are
always going to be preferred
indifference aren't they but they're not
going to be morally good as such and so
he says that these these have to do with
the things that are neither good nor bad
but some reasonable account some
plausible is another way of looking at
it
some proba probably this ratio can be
provided for why you should do this
action rather than this action we'll
take any an example that comes up a
little bit later on should you try to
manage your money well from a stoic
perspective that is indeed something
that has to do with indifference wealth
is totally indifferent although it's a
preferred indifferent and one of the
Stoics Diogenes who is the fourth leader
of the stoic school the fourth school
arc actually said well you know wealth
itself is useful for certain things it
can in fact conduce to health right you
spend your money on the right things and
you can become healthy
it is probably unhealthy to be poor
however whether you're wealthy or poor
whether you're healthy or sick doesn't
really make a difference when it comes
to whether you possess virtue or
happiness or not according to the Stoics
so the appropriate acts might be to
establish a budget and stick to the
budget right because it's one thing to
have a budget it's a very different
thing to actually follow through and
stick to the budget that you've
established and that would be an
appropriate act it's not something that
is good in and of itself but some sort
of reasonable explanation can be
provided for why you ought to do this
and you know you might say well can
to provide a reasonable explanation for
doing bad acts yes you can provide
rationalizations for them but you know
submit them to other people and see what
they think of them if they say wow your
reasoning is really off perhaps your
reasonable account is not quite so
reasonable he also tells us that when
appropriate acts are dealing with
indifference some things ought to be
chosen namely the the preferred
indifference we have to balance them
against each other as well and some of
them ought to be rejected and that
preference and rejection that is also a
matter of appropriate actions there's
one other distinction that he makes that
is particularly interesting and it helps
to reconnect appropriate acts to the
virtues so in the discussion of
appropriate acts he says listen you know
why is people that's the stoic you know
version of the good human being
the sage and everybody else they can all
do appropriate acts so that's not a
dividing line however the wise person is
going to do appropriate acts in a
somewhat different way than everybody
else will so he distinguishes between
right appropriate action and this is
complete appropriate action or action
that is done completely perfect them you
know it is brought to its full
conclusion and then there's incomplete
appropriate action this is just doing
the right thing in the circumstances but
not doing it you could say all the way
because you're not doing it in the right
way or for the right reason and the
example that he has is restoring a
deposit or a trust something that
somebody gives you and says hey give
this back to me when I need it could be
a cache of weapons it could be their
money it could be whatever you like and
so you've made some sort of promise do
you restore the trust
now you could restore it and say I don't
really think that you deserve this here
you go
right that would be doing it in
completely you could also risk
store it as he says rightly recta or
justly you step and this is a different
modality and that would be making it
right appropriate action or fully
developed appropriate action and this
ties into the virtues it goes back to
them because where do you get this
distinctions about how to do it rightly
or justly well from looking at what a
just or right morally right person would
in fact do so we have a reconnection
between appropriate acts which seem like
they're a little bit divorced from moral
goodness and the virtues and appropriate
acts are something that that occupies a
large part of our life so they play a
very important role within stoic ethics
even the wise person is going to be
doing a lot of appropriate act but
they're going to separate them from the
actual possession of the virtues
you